Hi everyone, and welcome to
another Google Developers
Live, where today we have a
pretty cool announcement for
the Google Drive SDK.
That is the addition of a new
part of the API for managing
comments and replies.
So actually, a feature a lot of
people have been asking for
for a long time, even before
Google Drive was called Google
Drive and we had a Google Docs
list and the various editors.
There's a lot of people that
love Google Docs and
Spreadsheets, and presentations,
and the
commenting and the reply
features, and
they're really great.
But if you're a developer and
you're trying to build
workflow applications around
Docs, and editing, and
workflow, they've just been
inaccessible in the past.
Starting today, these
are now available.
We're actually going to
show some examples of
how to use the API.
And those of you who have been
keeping an eye on our library
and our documentation, and the
client libraries, and getting
updates, you've probably
actually seen these in the
APIs already.
They've actually been there for
a couple weeks, but we're
just today making it official.
So let's switch over.
I just have a doc up here just
full of some randomly
generated--
some text and a couple
of comments.
Really, if you use Google Docs,
it should be really
familiar to most people.
But there are a couple of things
I want to point out
that we have.
We have comments, and
we have replies.
You can see this second
comment here.
This has reply.
And of course, we can do things
like edit and delete,
and resolve, add new replies.
All the functionality that
you get in [INAUDIBLE]
Editor is now available
via the API.
And the really cool part about
this is you can actually
manage comments and replies
for any file.
It's not just ours.
But if you're building your own
editor and you have your
own doc format, certainly
those files
are in Google Drive.
You can actually build your own
UI for managing comments,
take manager or API for the
storage and notifications that
come along with that, and just
make it behave very similar to
the editors that people are
already used to working with.
So to see actually how this
works from an API perspective,
I'm going to switch over
to our API's Explorer.
I should take a step
back here.
We have all of our APIs.
This is great tool for those who
aren't familiar with it.
If you are trying to learn some
of our APIs, the API's
Explorer is just
really awesome.
It gives you all of
our new APIs.
You can click in, drill
onto them, see all
the different methods.
And the ones that I want to
focus on today, of course, are
the drive.comments collection,
and we have, of course, a
corresponding drive.replies.
And really the main difference
is comments are--
comments and replies are
very similar, actually.
The difference is, comments are
attached to documents, and
replies are, of course,
attached to comments.
So it's just basically
a nested collection.
Let's go into our
drive.comments.list method here.
A great tool.
Again, tells you
what you need.
Really, all we need to list
comments is a file ID.
So I'm going to go back here,
and I'm just going to snag
this out of the URL.
And we'll execute this.
Also, if you're using this
tool and it gives you an
error, there is this little
button up here for authorizing
access to Drive.
I already did this a
little while ago.
My credentials are
still valid.
But let's actually take a look
at what the response was.
We can see here, we get back
a comment list collection.
And we can see it's a collection
of comments.
And in this case, we have two.
We have the two top-level
comments that one is a little
trivia bit about one of the
words that appeared in there,
and another one just about my
poor use of an example doc
using generic permission text.
And then within there, we
actually have a replies
collection.
So basically, everything that
we need in order to render a
UI for what is a comment
activity on a document, we
could actually just get
in a single call.
In addition, to getting the
actual content of the
comments, we actually get a lot
of information about who
the author was.
You get a display name.
You get a link to their
profile URL.
In this case, this particular
account doesn't have a profile
set up, so we're just
getting kind of the
generic person icon.
But if this were somebody who is
using Google+ and they had
a proper profile, you'd actually
be able to show an
image of that person, along with
their name, so that you
can have a very nice social
experience with displaying
those comments.
The other really important
bit here is this anchor.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit more about
this in a few minutes.
But this basically tells us
where in the document this
comment applies to.
In this case, because this is
our format, we do have a
proprietary anchoring scheme,
which does make it difficult
for, or actually rather
impossible for you to create
comments that are anchored to
text in our document formats.
But if it's a document format
that you control, or if it's
something where there's ways
to locate in a kind of an
interchangeable way-- and again,
I'll talk about this in
a little bit more
detail later--
you can put anchors in there
that your app can position
correctly and potentially, that
other apps could read and
position correctly as well.
So basically, we have content.
We have an author.
We have content.
We have the location.
And then, of course, we have the
replies which again, very
similar author information for
who made the reply along with
the content.
And of course, we have standard
stuff that we see in
most of our collections, whether
or not this is a
deleted comment or reply.
The status for comments is
actually pretty important for
marking things as
open comments.
That's still the action versus
resolved, indicating that the
people on the thread have
agreed that whatever the
comment was, that issue
is now addressed.
So pretty basic.
So let's actually try
creating a comment.
So I mentioned earlier that it's
not possible right now to
insert an anchored comment
into our documents.
That said, you can actually
insert an unanchored comment
into Google Docs.
So I'm going to say
this is a comment.
Let's keep that.
And it's successful.
We can see it.
It knows my author
information.
Creates it.
You can also put HTML
content in there.
Right now, I'm just putting
plain text, but if you want to
put HTML instead of plain text,
you can do that as well.
You could render comments with
some tags if it's bold or
italicized or strike
outs, and so on.
Now, I can actually
go up here.
And we see in our full comments
list, we have this
unanchored comment, which we
can either comment on or
resolve, or do whatever we
need to do, or delete.
If you want to do a reply to a
comment, it's actually not all
that difficult.
Let's go back and list our
comments again and
then our file ID.
And I'm going to
reply back to--
how about this thread
right here.
We do need our comment ID in
order to do this, so we should
have another tab open.
This is the replies/insert
method.
I had already copied a little
earlier while I put in the
file ID just to make life
a little easier.
And I'm going to put in
a comment ID as well.
And let's see.
And we'll just put
in something a
little silly and execute.
And I did not authenticate
recently enough on here.
I'll just reauthorize.
And here we go.
So now we were able to insert
a reply for that comment.
If we go back in here, this
actually updated, and we can
see that new reply.
So that's really the nature
of the comments/reply.
You have comments.
You have replies.
You can do all the normal
operations that you would do
in working with a list of files
you can do with comments.
So for example, by default,
deleted comments are removed
from the collection.
When you query for comments,
actually you can ask for
include deleted.
You can combine that with
updated min timestamps, if you
want to, for example, poll for
changes and find which
comments since the last time
you polled have been added,
which ones have been deleted.
If the comment is deleted, we do
return tombstone entries as
you would expect, and as we
do for most of our APIs.
And that's really it.
So I want to switch over to--
I've been mentioning anchors for
a while, and saying I want
to talk about them.
So really what I want to point
out is if you go to our
documentation page here, we
go to this new page here
/drive/managecomments.
And if you read through here,
there's actually a fairly
lengthy section here on talking
about anchoring
comments, and different schemes
here for interoperable
formats for anchoring content
to documents.
So for example, if you have
text, then there's a couple of
different schemes that
you might want to do.
You might want to anchor
a comment to a page.
You may want to do it
to a range of text.
This is basically using
offsets and how many
characters are in the range,
a line in a file.
Likewise, if you're doing things
like video or audio,
you might want to be able to
anchor comments to a point in
time in that audio or video
clip, and of course, give it a
range for how long of
that segment the
comment applies to.
There's also different formats
for regions and in image.
So if you're commenting on a
mock up for a new product and
you want to be able
to do things in an
image, you can do lines.
You can do--
or rather rectangles
or points.
And you can come up with your
own schemes as well.
We do recommend that if you
are doing your own scheme,
that you prefix it with
your application ID.
And even if you go back over
to here, you can see this
anchor scheme here
for our own.
Where's the anchor here?
The anchor here.
So this [INAUDIBLE] is basically
our internal app ID
for the document editor.
And this is just a custom marker
that is meaningful to
us but not to really
to anyone else.
So if you have, for example, an
XML document, a pretty good
anchoring scheme would
be something like
an XML element ID.
Likewise, if it's a format that
you can control and you
have markers that are meaningful
anchors for a
comment, any way that you can
identify those, feel free to
use those as an anchor
yourself.
One of the challenges with
anchors, however, is currently
in the version of the API that
just launched, the anchors are
immutable on a comment.
So this imposes certain
limitations.
For example, an anchor which
is based off of a line in a
text file, given that's
immutable, that anchor is only
relevant to a specific
revision of a file.
So you do need to make sure
that if you are anchoring
comments to a file based on some
sort of relative position
or offset to the file, where if
the content changes, that
might invalidate the anchor,
that you only use anchored
comments on read only files.
So for example, you're sending
out something for review.
You might want to make sure
that the people who are
commenting on it can't
modify the file.
That it's going to be
static for at least
some period of time.
The anchoring scheme does
actually have a field for the
revision ID, so that you do know
that if the content has
changed, that you may have to
invalidate those comments as
the positions may no
longer be relevant.
It is something that we do plan
on changing to make sure
that anchors can be changed
so that if you do need to
reposition them as a file
changes and those positions
change, that you'll be
able to do that.
But for now, basically, the
recommendation is either use
anchored comments on read only
files if you're using one of
these kind of positioned anchors
where it's sensitive
to the format of the document.
The second option would be
to use a custom scheme.
This would be something, again,
if you have a format
that you can control and you can
embed the anchors, or if
you have some natural structures
like XML element
IDs, then just use the custom
scheme that you can manage.
And then if the structure of
the content changes, the
structure of the file changes,
rather, and if those anchors
were to be deleted, you would
have at least some way to
detect whether or not
a comment was
still valid or not.
And of course, the third option
is just to forego using
anchors, then you could just use
document-level comments,
which are still really valuable
for a lot of content.
You just have to kind of figure
out depending on what
type of file you're doing.
But again, for a lot of the
formats that we're seeing
people do, they are proprietary
formats and have a
lot more flexibility for
embedding anchors.
And in those cases, the API is
actually really easy to use
and very powerful.
I'm trying to think if there's
anything else that is really
worth noting.
The permissions are actually
pretty important.
So one of the things a couple
of people have asked about
early on when we launched
the Drive API was in our
permission list, we did
have a commenter role.
And of course, a lot of people
wondered why do you have a
commenter role if there's no
comment in functionality.
Now you know.
There's actually a good reason
for using that role.
And it starts to make a lot more
sense if you are building
in commenting functionality
into your app, to start to
honor that role whether or not
somebody has either owner edit
or commenting permissions,
then you would enable the
features for adding a comment.
If they don't have any of those
roles, then you want to
make sure that you disable those
features in your UI so
that the users doesn't try to
create a comment and then get
an error when they actually
try to save it.
But again, the same practice
that you should be doing
anyway for a drive application
always making sure that you
check ahead of time whether or
not the user has permission,
not for security, but really
for usability just to make
sure that the user doesn't go
too far down any particular
path when the end result
is doomed to fail.
But really that is
really about it.
We do have a couple of trusted
testers who have
been working on this.
I do expect in the next few
weeks that we will see a
number of applications out
there come out with
integration with the
comments APIs.
Some of them, I think, are
going to be really cool.
And once those start coming up
in the Chrome Web Store or in
other places, we'll try to point
them out as an example
for people.
But other than that, have
fun with the API.
I'm really excited to see what
people are going to do with
this, and that's really
about it.
Join us again next time.
We do have some more features
coming up pretty soon.
And I do believe we are
off for next week.
It is Thanksgiving, and even
though we're normally here
early in the week, I think we're
going to just take the
whole week off.
But after that, come back,
and we'll have some more
announcements.
We have some new quick starts
that we've been working on.
Actually an iOS quick start
just got posted yesterday.
We'll do a session on that.
Again, a couple more features,
a little bit smaller than
comments, but are some really
cool and useful stuff coming
up as well.
And other than that, thank
you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]